mélanie deslauriers a le coeur gros il y
a quelques semaines elle a décidé de
fermer son service de garde se trouve
car c'est un milieu qui était spécial
pic à cause de cette nouvelle de ces
nouvelles lois la hanche près pu rester
ouverte
la loi 143 impose de nouveaux critères
concernant le ratio des services de
garde en milieu familial non reconnu par
le ministère de la famille les enfants
des propriétaires âgés de 9 ans et moins
sont désormais inclus dans le calcul du
nombre de petits dans ces garderies
le maximum est de 6 pour une mère de
deux filles comme c'est le cas pour
mélanie des lauriers ça veut dire
seulement quatre enfants de l'extérieur
la perte de revenu est trop importante
pour continuer à fonctionner d'environ
350 $ par semaine donc je fais vraiment
paul arrivé avec son mari un flux qui
augmente vraiment trop mon tarif
journalier pour les parents sarpei bon
sens est possible aussi pour un
propriétaire d'être remplacé en cas
d'absence la seule option sera de fermer
pour la journée
l'association québécoise des milieux
familiaux éducatif privé créé une vague
de fermeture pourtant quarante deux
mille enfants attendent une place dans
des services de garde reconnu présentant
la vie des parents qui perdent leurs
services de la voirie on va même y est
vous avant qu'il soit élu et minutes
chacun qui l'avait dit avec là pour vous
et à koné fait des manifestations
étaient là pour nous piété à comprenais
pas ce qui se passait mais une fois élu
a été totalement nu disco pour le
gouvernement legault pas question de
reculer même si la loi était imposé par
le précédent gouvernement
les temps ont changé on ya un moment où
on veut davantage de qualité à nos
enfants ou aux rup soit davantage
donc tant mieux qu'ils étaient non
régime et que les enfants étaient super
bien géré un mystère que les
gouvernements viennent voir chez moi
comme un sens comme à les parents sont
satisfaits avant de faire tous ces
changements
l'association québécoise des milieux
familiaux éducatif privé consulte
actuellement des juristes afin de
décider s'ils vont contester cette
nouvelle loi ici pierre alexandre bolduc
radio canada québec